عندما اندلعت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في
فبراير الماضي اعتقد البعض ان ادواتها
ستقتصر على الصواريخ والدبابات والطائرات
وكل العتاد العسكري المعروف لكن خلال مسار
الحرب ظهرت ادوات اخرى ابرزها مصادر
الطاقه كانت تاثير الاول اندلاع الحرب هو
الارتفاع الكبير لسعر النفط سجل خام برنت
139 دولارا للبرميل خلال شهر مارس شكلت
هذه الاسعار وتحديه للاقتصاد العالمي الذي
كان يخته خطوات التعات الاولى من وباقي
كورونا وبدت اوروبا متخوفه اكثر من غيرها
من حرب الطاقه فقبل اندلاع الحرب كان
الغاز الروسي يشكل نسبه تراوح بين 40 و
45% من حاجيات دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الغاز تحصل عليها عبر شبكه من الانابيب
كان الكريم يعرف ان هذه نقطه ضعف
الاوروبيين الكبرى واكتشف الاوروبيون فجاه
ان سهوله حصولي على مصادر الطاقه الروسيه
انستهم هذه الحقيقه بعد فشل الهجوم الروسي
الاول وبعد فرض عقوبات غربيه على روسيا
بدا الرئيس الروسي بعد بوتين شهر مايو في
خفض تدفق الغازي الى اوروبا ادرك
الاوروبيون ان حرب الطاقه قد بدات وتوقعوا
خسائر فادحه خصوصا مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
في شهر اغسطس وصل سعر الغازي الى نحو 340
يورو الميجاوات في الساعه وهو رقم لم
يبلغه من قبل ارتفعت اسعار الكهرباء
بالنسبه للمواطن الاوروبي بنسبه 35%
مقارنه بالسنه الماضيه خرجت مظاهرات في
مدن اوروبيه عده للمطالبه بخطوات تخفف من
وطاه اسعار الكهرباء على المواطن وتدعو
المسؤولين الاوروبيين الى البحث عن حلول
زادت الضغوط وبعدها هجمات تعرض لها انبوب
الغاز نور ستريم تبادل روسيا ودو تربيه
المسؤوليه عنها كان واضحا ان الرئيس
الروسي يسعى لتضييق الخناق اكثر على
الاوروبيين لوقف دعمهم لاوكرانيا اختار
الاوروبيون التحدي وبداوا هجوم مضاده قرر
المجلس الاوروبي وقف الاعتماد على النفط
الروسي بنسبه 90% مع نهايه 2022 ودعى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الدول الاعضاء الى خفض
الاستهلاك بشكل طبيعي بنسبه 15% كما بدات
عمليه تخزين غير مسبوقه بالاعتماد على دول
ابرزها الولايات المتحده التي زودتها
بكميات كبيره من الغاز المسال وبحلول شهر
نوفمبر كانت الخزانات مملوءه بنسبه 95%
وتراجعت نسبه الغازي الروسي المستورد الى
سبعه في المئه من الحجيات لكن اوروبا لم
تبدو دائما موحده في وجه التحدي الذي فرضه
عليها الرئيس الروسي فقد ظهرت خلافات بشان
وضع سقف لاسعار الغاز استمرت اربعه اشهر
ليتفق في الاخير على 180 يورو للميجاوات
في الساعه رفضت روسيا بطبع هذا القرار
واعتبرته اعتداء على قواعد السوق حرب
اوكرانيا دفعت اوروبا الى اتخاذ قرار
انهاء الاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه الروسيه
لكن التوقعات تشير الى ان الوضع في السنه
المقبله قد يكون اسوا من هذه السنه ولذلك
في الاوروبيون مطالبون بالبحث عن مزيد من
البدائل في اقرب وقت